e nas brincadeira de Infância eu era o
cara que fazia a confusão na brincadeira
porque eu nunca estava satisfeito com o
que tava acontecendo temha uma
brincadeira que eu não sei se tem aí
onde vocês mora mas onde eu moro tinha
chamada vaca amarela que tinha uma
musiquinha assim ó vaca amarela cagou na
panela quem falar primeiro come a bosta
dela todo mundo calava a boca ao som de
vaca amarela o menino podia ter caído
arrumado os Dent no chão quebrado a cara
toda podia estar chorando o calar a
boca cala a boca
rapaz meu filho tem visita aqui em casa
rapaz faz silêncio que o povo tá quendo
Conversar vaca amarela cagou na panela
quem falar primeiro come a boch
dela mas não escutava nenhum PI